[Music]
[Applause]
part of NBC football night in America
Rodney Harrison two-time Super Bowl
champ with the Patriots and maybe one
day he'll get into the Pro Football Hall
of Fame or at least be a finalist
because I think there's only two players
in NFL history who've had at least 30
sacks and 30 interceptions one is Rodney
Harrison I think the other one is Ray
Lewis does that sound right Paulie that
sounds right all right spring and Rodney
Harrison who joins us now Rodney what's
your question that you have today with
what you saw the last couple of days
with tuatanga by law
Dan I tell you man I was at a football
game my son's football game last night
when I was watching it on my phone
and man my heart dropped when I saw that
kid laying on a football field and he
was just frozen and his hands were stuck
like this it scared the living crap out
of me and I played this game 15 years
and I've had multiple multiple
concussions where I hit somebody the
stadium was spinning I didn't know where
I was at so that's considered a
concussion but but nothing like that has
ever happened to me and I don't know how
you come back on the football field
after that happens to you
um we're talking about this kid's life
we're talking about myself as well as so
many other football players that I know
friends of mine that live here in
Atlanta that suffer from CTE that suffer
from depression that suffer from light
sensitivity that suffer and and it
affects their relationship with their
kids and their parents this is something
serious there's no way in the world this
kid should go back into football on a
football field in the next week or so
then this is Dead series well I go back
to Sunday Rodney and okay they told me
it was a back injury but
I mean he certainly displayed symptoms
of having a concussion he was out on his
feet so what did you see as a former
player if you saw your teammate react
like that
and how surprised would you be that he
was going to be able to come back into a
game
I would have been shocked you talk about
me a guy that was very physical flying
around and when I saw him I just thought
it was a concussion I said man get down
get down because it's a concussion but
then they said it was a back problem but
the way he stumbled it was to me it was
more mental it was more neurological so
I don't know what they're doing if
they're doing anything funny with this
kid's life but at the end of the day
eventually one day he's going to walk
away from football and he's going to
have a life he's going to have wife and
kids and he's going to have uh to
sustain a normal life and when you get
hit hit upside the head like that and
when you fall down and when you're
basically paralyzed for 30 seconds or
whatever it was it's going to affect
your quality life later on
how often would you lie when you got
hurt
every single time every single time and
you don't get to the level of what tool
got to and accomplish the things that
he's accomplished in his career without
lines without basically saying no I'm
good no I'm good it's my back these
players are smart they know if they say
anything that's wrong with their head
they know they're coming out of the game
they know they're gonna miss a series or
two or possibly the entire game so the
first thing they do oh it's not my head
it's my back it's my ankle it's my
shoulder and um you know I would have
been one of those guys too but I just
know sitting here turning 50 this year
that I'm looking at this young man and
said man he's got so much potential for
the rest of his life he doesn't need to
be out on that football field like that
but he might have lied to the medical
staff and said that it was his back I
mean the player does play a role Drew
Brees said he lied all the time when he
got hurt you're saying that he lied all
the time and you know what you know what
they should do they should start
bringing former guys like me and those
guys that lie I bring them in there and
talk to the guys and talk to them talk
to them about the quality of life that
we have right now yeah we're doing okay
financially and things like that but at
the end of the day it's more than just
you know money it's being able to
communicate being able to sustain
relationships and have friends and
things like that yeah but I'm talking to
Rodney as a dad who's 50 years of age if
Rodney is a 24 year old
you're going to do what Tua did
exactly that's but that's my whole point
Dan that's why you need guys like me old
school guys that used to lie to come in
and say hey guys you shouldn't be lying
about this this is your life this is
your brain this is you know that's what
I'm saying okay yeah but what was the uh
the protocol that did you ever lie to
Belichick and just say I'm good I'm you
know I'm staying in the game
yeah all the time and I stayed in the
game and if I didn't have anything major
like an ACL or a pulled hamstring or
groin or something like that there's no
way you're taking me out out of the
football game because we're just wired a
certain way we're wired to be able to go
out there hit we know we're gonna be in
a little pain to talk to you all the
time about toughness and your ability to
you know stay in the game and that's
what football players do man you know if
if it's if it's a head injury we're
staying in the game if it's something
lower extremity that we can't control
we're coming out the game I I tell this
story all the time that uh you know a
player said that he he got his Bell rung
Hines Ward I've said his name before he
you know takes a hit against the Ravens
he he knows he's concussed he grabs his
ankle
he's smart enough to know that I'm gonna
grab my ankle and try to stay in the
game because I got hurt my bell is wrong
and then he said he went to the
sidelines they had to hide his helmet
from him
yeah and I'll tell you this then when
you wake up after all those years of
plan over a decade in National Football
League and now you're in your 40s and
you're you're you know close to your 50s
you sit back and you reflect on those
moments that you know you you didn't
come out the game that you lied because
it's affected you wake up and you're
depressed you wake up and you're sad you
wake up and you're going through all
these different mental and emotional
things
that's where it affects you later on in
life and that's what that's my biggest
concern with these guys but are you
speaking from experience absolutely 100
that's the only way I can speak I can't
speak upon when you go through
depression you we all go through
depressing anytime you play football and
you have CTE yeah we all go through a
form of depression but it's you know
it's about how you take care of yourself
but yeah we go through a a bravery of uh
emotions and things like that that's why
I say a lot of times when you have CTE
when you're dealing with guys that have
been concussed it's hard to maintain
certain relationships it's hard to
establish new relationships a lot of
times you don't even want to go out the
house and that's my concern with tour
and the rest of these guys their
lifestyle when they're done playing
football because think about it if
you're fortunate enough you'll play
eight to ten years and when you turn 30
you're concussed you can't focus you
can't do certain things so that's my
biggest concern with these guys letting
them know man it's okay to sit out a
game or two if you have to to make sure
that your brain is taken care of and
make sure that you have the quality of
life that you you deserve later on he's
Rodney Harrison football night in
America analyst former Patriot it'll be
uh his former teammate Tom Brady
battling Patrick Mahomes the Buccaneers
hosting the Chiefs on Sunday Night
Football biggest question going into
that football game is what for you
um pressure you know anytime you're
going up against Tom you got to get that
pressure and deterior that defense I
look at Kansas City and they have a
bunch of pass rushes Carlos Dunlap and
Chris Jones and all those guys Frank
Clark they got to get after Tom if they
can get after Tom and Steve Spagnola
he's had success against Tom their
defensive coordinator beat him in the
Super Bowl he's had success against Tom
if they can hit Tom and rattle Tom
especially going against that
inexperienced offensive line forced him
to communicate show him a bunch of
different looks I think they can have
success
do you think we we have addictions you
know there's a lot of different
addictions we have and I wonder is is
Brady addicted to football
or competition like is it something that
is more than just I love doing this I'm
addicted to it well I think a lot of
guys are like built like Tom Brady but a
lot of guys couldn't do the things that
Tom did for such a long time because Tom
just has an extraordinary amount of
discipline obviously and um it's It's
just tough to get to that level I mean
he's a quarterback he's sustained for a
long time most guys can't get to that
point because like I said you know we're
trying to get there but we get old but
yeah there's there's definitely an
addiction there there's definitely an
obsession there with just being great
and but also there's a certain level of
enjoyment like going through the week
with your teammates and riding the plane
with them and getting on the bus and
having certain conversations those are
the things that you really cherish and
you Embrace and you know Tom's fortunate
enough to play over 20 years in this
league he continues to do that and uh
but yeah definitely an obsession Dan you
got to be obsessed to be um you know to
be on a level with Tom Brady
how would you have dealt with Tyreek
Hill as a defensive back
um you know probably just Jam them at
the line of scrimmage keep a safety on
top of them but I look at Kansas City
and they did the right thing I mean
everybody why would you get rid of
Tyreek Hill no why would you pay a wide
receiver 30 million dollars a year it's
the dumbest thing I don't care who you
are I'm not paying you 30 million
dollars a year so it was a smart move to
let him walk and get these other guys
these other guys they're not great Dan
but they're serviceable and that's why
you pay Matt Patrick Mahomes the type of
money you pay him so he can make these
other guys better and and I thought it
was a smart move getting rid of Tyrique
yeah you know we look at these
quarterbacks and a lot of times these
quarterbacks make their receivers better
Tom certainly did that in New England I
mean he had Gronk who is a Hall of Famer
but there are other guys who you know
were good receivers Tom made them
elevated them it felt like uh Rogers
maybe does that a little bit now Mahomes
is going to have to do that in Kansas
City but can they be a better offense
without Tyree kill
[Music]
I don't I don't think they could be a
better offense or a more dangerous
offense or a more explosive offense I
think they're going to be a different
offense I think it's going to require
patience it's going to require continued
communication and meetings and things
like that I mean you look at Tyreek Hill
when he gets on a football field as a
defense and as a defensive coordinator
he scares you he scares you I don't care
if you have two guys on you because how
many times Dan have we seen Patrick
Mahomes throw the ball 50 yards down the
field you got two defensive backs and
Tyree killed the smallest guy on the
field comes up with it and and they
don't have the ability like they did
before for Tyree to catch a seven yard
slant and take it 60 yards to the house
that puts the fear of God into people
when you're out there on that football
field now you don't have to deal with it
I mean so you I don't think it'll become
a more dangerous offense I just think
that it's going to be a different
offense but would you rather go against
a wide receiver who was an unbelievable
route Runner
somebody who was big physical or
somebody who could just fly give me the
receiver that gives you the most trouble
to me it's it's the guy that's an
excellent route Runner that could put
pressure on you because you don't know
if he's going deep you don't know if
it's going to be a comeback an out route
a corner out you don't know what he's
running because he's such an excellent
route Runner I played against guys like
James Jett and really fast guys for the
Raiders that you know we basically said
hey we're going to give this guy any
curl route any short or any immediate
route we can't allow him to beat us Deep
And as far as Tyree kill a guy like that
you just got to get your hands on them
you have to have someone spy them and
just keep somebody on top and every time
that little Joker catches the ball you
gotta punish him you gotta hit him then
you gotta punish him and you got to take
that smile off his face okay but Calvin
Johnson how much trouble with Calvin
Johnson Calvin Johnson was a monster man
he was big he was long and uh that those
50 50 balls we talk about that and I
feel bad for him man because he played
for such a crummy team for such a long
time and we don't realize how good he he
truly is yeah he's in the Hall of Fame
but people don't understand how great of
a football player this dude was he was
big super athletic and he was a bully
but he was a humble bully
um but yeah Calvin Johnson all props to
him
uh where does Rodney rank on the
all-time playoff interception list
career playoff interceptions Rodney
Harrison is third I'll tied for third
all-time with seven the only people
ahead of him are guys like Ed Reed
Ronnie Lott Willie Brown Hall of Fame
Hall of Fame okay Mr Hayes yeah you're
good company there right
hey man it's a Dan let me tell you
something brother it happens when it
happens right okay never late have you
heard feedback on why you haven't been a
finalist for the Hall of Fame Dan I
don't go searching for that stuff no no
I didn't know if like Peter King was
listening listen to me Peter King it
doesn't even have my back and that was
supposed to be my homeboy wait he
doesn't believe you're a Hall of Famer
I mean he's never said anything to me
and I've worked with him a long time but
it's all good I mean I'm not I'm not
worried about that I got love for Peter
King
um I mean Dan it's one of those things I
don't go searching for it if it happens
it's gonna happen uh when it's supposed
to happen if it's gonna happen if not
hey man I got my two Super Bowl rings
I'm able to take care of my family and
life is pretty good but you got
Belichick who talks about how great you
were like your name was first when he
brought up great players who played for
him so again if you Dan if you and the
guys are sitting in a room and I've I've
done all the things I can possibly do
yeah you know you know on a football
field what what else can I do I'm not
gonna go around begging and parading or
anything like that man I just if if it
happens fine if it doesn't I'm okay with
it I know what I represented I know the
people that I've impacted and that's the
most important thing for me well I think
Heinz Ward came out and he got feedback
as to why he's not in the Hall of Fame
that
Heinz Ward always felt like he was a
Hall of Famer you played it I felt like
how high it's Ward is definitely a Hall
of Fame can you talk about one of the
toughest one of the most Dependable
um guys that put fear in you is Heinz
Ward I mean one of the most physical if
not the most physical all time like
who's tougher than Heinz war and you
know it's I'm not in that room so I
don't know I walk I go down to the Hall
of Fame game and I got 50 Hall of Famers
you know coming up to me oh man you're
gonna be in a Hall of Fame amen I've
been talking about you in the Hall of
Fame and I'm looking at him like Hey man
I just say I'm just here enjoying myself
you know everyone looks at me like I'm
so desperate to get in a Hall of Fame
and it's it's just not the case who is
dirty or you or Heinz word
um Heinz was my offense he was my
offensive twin
maybe we will go in together and then
hit each other on stage that'd be great
hey Dan but I'm gonna tell you this the
cool part about Heinz and our our
relationship we were we would play
against each other and I will jog on the
field and I'm like Hans what kind of day
is going to be man what what we good
because if you did because if you give
me a t-shirt
I don't care if it cost me a hundred
grand 200 Grand I'm coming for you wait
how much how much did the jury Rice hit
cost you 100 grand
it cost me a game check back then which
was in the 90s it was about a hundred
and twenty two thousand dollars
it was worth it
absolutely you can't miss what you never
had I've never had that money in my bank
account so screw it I'm gonna not Jerry
Rice head off
and Jerry is my man but he's hey he's
got to pay the price too yeah came
across he paid the price you paid the
price
absolutely hey great to talk to you
again
um my best to the guys on football night
in America
thank you Dan Fitz good to see you man
uh it's Rodney Harrison NBC football
night in America and they got the
Buccaneers and the Chiefs that'll be
Sunday night they start at seven Eastern
take a break uh we'll get phone calls
coming up and I think we're gonna hear
from Matt Leinart coming up next hour
Fritz who's working on that we're back
after this